la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu l'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
je n'envoie point le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
notre région appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement mais
auparavant je formule pour chacune et
chacun d'entre vous les meilleurs vœux
pour cette année qui a maintenant
commencé et nous aurons qu'à l'occasion
de revoir la semaine prochaine pour les
formuler plus plus directement et
spécifiquement je vous rappelle que
notre séance c'est retransmise en direct
sur Public Sénat sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif
au respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
uns et des autres ou du respect du temps
de parole mais je voudrais saluer la
présence de notre nouvelle collègue
madame Monique delfabro sénatrice de la
Meurthe-et-Moselle qui remplace Philippe
lagard je lui souhaite la bienvenue
[Musique]
au nom du Sénat
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant donner la parole au
président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen monsieur le Président vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre
avec la réforme des retraites il y a le
quoi faire sauter plusieurs
gouvernements affirmer Michel Rocard
ancien Premier de François Mitterrand
c'est donc un courage madame la Première
ministre que vous attaquez à cette
réforme vous avez au cours de dernière
semaine beaucoup consulté partie groupe
politique et bien entendu les syndicats
comme président du groupe RDSE vous
m'avez reçu à l'Hôtel Matignon avec mon
collègue Cabanel en prenant des
ministres du socle et restèrent nous
avons fait part de nos préoccupations et
de nos interrogations et au cours d'une
discussion franche et ouverte vous a
donné des précisions sur la pénibilité
et l'usure professionnelle la question
des carrières longues l’emploi du
seniors l'avenir des régies spéciaux et
l'augmentation des pensions minimales
vous avez dit voyez hier votre projet au
sein duquel l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite sera finalement fixé à 64 ans
en 2030 au lieu au lieu des 65 ans
envisagé sur ce point qui Crist de
nombreux mécontentement pourquoi ne pas
maintenir l'âge légal à 62 ans et tenir
compte uniquement des trimestres cotisés
qui détermineraient le montant des
pensions une modulation de la durée de
cotisation selon les situations de
certaines pas le système le plus
équitable et un compromis dans la
tradition radicale mais sans radicalité
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Roquier je voudrais tout
d'abord présenter mes meilleurs vœux à
toutes les sénatrices et sénateurs à
leurs équipes et au service du Sénat
alors monsieur le Président Roquier le
système de retraite par répartition est
au cœur de notre modèle social les
Français y sont profondément attachés
nous l'avons évoqué à plusieurs reprises
je sais que vous même et votre groupe
Led aussi je partage cette attachement
et avec mon gouvernement nous sommes
résolus à agir pour préserver notre
système de retraite par répartition mais
aujourd'hui chacun le sait le nombre de
personnes qui travaillent par rapport au
nombre de retraités diminue menaçant
notre modèle
aussi après des mois de concertation
j'ai annoncé hier notre projet pour
garantir l'avenir de nos retraites un
projet d'équilibre d'abord nous refusons
d'augmenter les impôts ou de baisser les
pensions le seul chemin possible c'est
donc de travailler progressivement plus
longtemps comme vous l'avez dit nous
porterons l'âge légal de départ à 64 ans
en 2030 et nous allons également
accélérer la mise en place de la réforme
Touraine pour atteindre 43 années de
cotisation en 2027 comme vous le voyez
cela rejoint les grandes lignes du
dispositif voté par le Sénat depuis
plusieurs années quant à l'âge
d'annulation de la décote il est et
restera à 67 ans c'est important pour
les nombreuses femmes qui doivent aller
jusqu'à cet âge pour ne pas avoir de
décote sur leurs pensions
grâce à cela notre système sera à
l'équilibre en 2030 alors je suis bien
consciente de ce que cela signifie pour
beaucoup de nos compatriotes c'est
pourquoi nous avons construit un projet
de justice
celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler plus tôt pourront partir plus
tôt les carrières des femmes souvent
incomplètes ou hachée seront mieux pris
en compte la pénibilité des métiers sera
mieux reconnue nous continuerons à tenir
compte des plus fragiles un départ à 62
ans sera toujours possible pour les
personnes en invalidité en incapacité ou
en inaptitude au total quatre Français
sur 10 souvent les plus fragiles les
plus modestes celles et ceux qui ont des
métiers difficiles pourront partir avant
64 ans j'ajoute que la justice c'est
aussi fermer la plupart des régimes
spéciaux car le même métier doit donner
la même retraite et ce n'est pas tout
notre projet se rapporteur de progrès
social
conformément à l'engagement du président
de la République nous allons augmenter
la retraite minimale pour une carrière
complète au niveau du SMIC à 85% du SMIC
soit une hausse de 100 euros par mois et
ce dès cette année nous avons aussi
entendu l'appel de plusieurs groupes
politiques et d'organisation syndicales
et patronales et je vous confirme que
l'augmentation de la retraite minimale
concernera bien les retraités actuels au
total près de 2 millions de Français
verront leur pension revalorisée dès
cette année ce sont d'abord des femmes
ce sont d'abord des commerçants et des
artisans qui ont travaillé toute leur
vie c'est un progrès social majeur
enfin nous voulons rendre aux salariés
proches de la retraite toutes leurs
places en entreprise avec davantage de
transparence sur les politiques des
employeurs avec l'assouplissement de la
retraite progressive et avec un cumulent
retraite plus avantageux alors monsieur
le Président Roquier aujourd'hui mon
ambition avec mon gouvernement avec tous
ceux qui veulent préserver notre système
de retraite par répartition c'est de
convaincre autour de ce projet c'est de
chercher à l'améliorer avec le Parlement
et je sais que le Sénat il prendra toute
sa part c'est de construire ensemble un
système juste équilibré et porteur de
progrès social je vous remercie
9 3 il n'y aura sûrement pas les
questions préalables dont le débat ira
son terme et nous notre groupe il
prendra toute sa part et permettez-moi
un petit rappel historique au début du
siècle au début du règne de Louis XVI
général des finances parce qu'il est
difficile il a proposé les mesures
audacieuses ambitieuses certaines
suppressions de privilèges et ils ont eu
cette formule la réforme plutôt que la
révolution quelques années après il y a
pas eu d'informes quelques années après
il y a eu la Révolution et bien j'espère
que cette réforme des retraites
n'amènera pas la révolution
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
remonte pour ces Monges pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez présenté hier une
réforme des retraites qui allonge de
nouveaux de deux ans l'âge de départ à
la retraite vous avez balayé nos
solutions alternatives pour combler un
déficit que vous dramatisez sciemment et
qu'il n'aurait jamais dû être un
problème si le fond de réserve des
retraites n'avait pas été siphonné mais
alimenté comme prévu vous vous gardez de
présenter le bilan de la Contre-Réforme
de 2010 que vous vous apprêtez à copier
soit la baisse tendancielle du montant
des pensions et de la durée de vie à la
retraite selon l'adresse en 2016 la
réforme de 2010 avait déjà fait perdre
presque un an de durée de retraite à la
génération 80 en cumulant toutes les
réformes depuis 2010 plusieurs
générations perdront jusqu'à 20 mois de
durée de la retraite non seulement ces
réformes ont affectées au travail la
grande partie des gains d'espérance de
vie mais votre réforme va empiéter les
années de vie à la retraite en bonne
santé et il n'y a rien de plus
inégalitaire quand selon l'Inde l'écart
de vie en bonne santé de 10 ans entre
catégories socioprofessionnelles votre
réforme s'attaque au droit au repos de
tous les travailleurs mais quand une
plus dur sur les classes populaires les
ouvriers les employés comme avant
allonger le sas de précarité des ni en
emploi ni en retraite pour une partie au
chômage ou au RSA dont vous réduisez
dans le même temps les droits l'attaque
contre le monde du travail et la
protection sociale est frontale et
systémique et dévoile ce que recouvre le
credo du travail plus pour perdre sa vie
à la gagner et détruire l'habitabilité
de notre retraite de notre planète
pardon monsieur le ministre pensez-vous
qu’après une crise sanitaire qui a
interrogé la place et le sens du travail
à l'heure des urgences il est
responsable d'imposer une réplique de la
Contre-Réforme inégalitaire de 2010 et
ce contre une très large majorité des
Français et des représentants syndicaux
pour vous répondre la parole des taux
ministres du travail fait l'emploi de
l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du socle
vous avez la parole merci merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
finalement au travers de votre question
vous nous dites est-ce qu'il faut faire
une réforme des retraites la réponse est
oui elle est positive pour trois raisons
trois raisons que vous retrouverez dans
le rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites que dit ce rapport ce rapport
dit d'abord que le système est
déficitaire déficitaire dès 2023 avec
une perte d'un milliard 8 déficitaire en
2027 avec un déficit de 12,5 milliards
d'euros déficitaire en 2030 avec presque
15 milliards d'euros puis 20 milliards
d'euros par an en 2035 25 milliards
d'euros en 2040 et l'enjeu de cette
réforme c'est aussi de préserver un
système de répartition de le préserver
avec d'autant plus d'attention que les
chiffres que je donne à l'instant sont
des chiffres qui sont prévus par le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites dans
l'hypothèse où nous aurions atteint
qu'un emploi c'est-à-dire une hypothèse
à laquelle nous participons que nous
souhaitons mais qui reste une très
optimiste et si le plein emploi n'était
pas au rendez-vous les chiffres seraient
encore plus dégradés et le système
serait encore plus en danger le premier
ail de solidarité c'est de permettre aux
génération qui viennent de conserver un
système de répartition et de le faire
sans être étouffé par la dette ni
assommé par les impôts la deuxième
raison pour laquelle il faut faire cette
réforme c'est parce que si nous la
faisons pas là aussi c'est le rapport du
corps qui le dit le niveau de vie des
retraités va baisser et je ne suis pas
sûr madame la sénatrice que vous
souhaitiez retrouver la situation des
années 70 quand les retraités étaient
les pauvres du pays alors même que notre
système para répartition a permis aux
retraité justement d'avoir un niveau de
vie qui soit identique à celui de
l'ensemble des Français et puis il y a
une troisième raison c'est une raison
démographique que la chef du
gouvernement a exposé à la fin des
années 70 nous étions trois actifs à
cotisés pour un retraité aujourd'hui
nous sommes un tout petit peu plus de
1,5 actifs pour un retraité c'est la
démonstration ça ne tient pas puisque ça
ne tient pas il faut réparer réparer
avec des mesures d'accompagnement sur la
disponibilité sur les carrières longues
pour protéger les plus fragiles réparer
dans le débat et je dis devant le Sénat
parce que la responsable de votre partie
la responsable des vers au niveau
national a appelé de ses vœux que
l'Assemblée nationale soit transformée
en ZAD ça n'est pas notre conception de
la démocratie et je souhaite comment ici
nous puissions mener un débat apaisé
quelques secondes
quelques secondes monsieur oui monsieur
le ministre la réponse vous sera donnée
le 19 par la mobilisation des français
auprès des organisations syndicales et
des parties de la gauche et écologiste
la parole est à notre collègue Franck
Menonville pour le groupe Les
Indépendants Républiques et territoires
mon cher collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en raison
des hausses exorbitantes des coûts de
l'énergie dans mon département de la
Meuse ce sont déjà sept boulangers qui
ont cessé leur activité
pour faire face à l'augmentation des
prix des matières premières certains
boulangers ont déjà dû réévaluer leur
prix de vente une nouvelle augmentation
tarifaire serait aujourd'hui
inenvisageable mais pour grand nombre
d'entre eux la situation est aujourd'hui
intenable face à cela différentes
mesures à destination des boulangers ont
été annoncées le 4 janvier dernier je ne
reviendrai pas sur les conditions
d'éligibilité néanmoins concernant le
bouclier tarifaire 80% des boulangeries
ne peuvent aujourd'hui prétendre car
elle dépasse le seuil de 36 kW avec
l'utilisation des fours des chambres
froides des pétrins et des vitrines
certes l'amortisseur électricité devrait
pouvoir s'activer mais nos boulangers
nous alertent régulièrement sur le prix
de 180 euros le mégawatts qui selon eux
restent trop pénalisant et encore pas
assez protecteur les conditions des
visibilité ne sont pas suffisamment
adaptées aux difficultés rencontrées par
la profession et les démarches et les
démarches sont perçues comme trop
complexes pour que les dispositifs
soient accessibles et rapidement
applicables il faut s'appuyer sur les
réseaux local et notamment faciliter la
compréhension de ces dispositifs les
accompagnements annoncés vont certes
dans le bon sens mais force est de
constater qu'ils sont insuffisants au
regard de l'intensité des difficultés de
la profession monsieur le ministre
est-ce que le gouvernement entend
proposé un dispositif plus protecteur
pour les TPE les plus impactés il me
semble important et urgent d'envisager
un déplafonnement de la puissance de 36
kilowatts pour étendre ainsi le bénéfice
du bouclier tarifaire ce serait là une
mesure simple et bien comprise
pour vous répondre la parole des
communistes de l'économie des finances
et de la souveraineté de Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire merci monsieur le Président
Madame et Monsieur sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
vous avez aujourd'hui à peu près 2,1
million de très petites entreprises
moins de 10 salariés moins de 2 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires vous
l'avez rappelé 1,5 millions d'entre
elles sont protégés par des tarifs
régulés parce qu'elles ont une puissance
électrique inférieure à 36 kg a donc
elle elles sont totalement couvertes par
le bouclier tarifaire et n'auront pas
d'augmentation leurs factures
d'électricité de plus de 15%. je
rappelle qu'il n'y a aucun autre pays
européen qui propose cela à ces très
petites entreprises des récits très
petites entreprises alors on aurait pu
effectivement étendre le TRV à C600
mille entreprises le coût était de 3
milliards d'euros et j'aurais
certainement bénéficié à quelques
milliers de boulangers mais il serait si
bénéficier à des centaines de milliers
d'autres entreprises qui n'en ont pas
nécessairement besoin alors qu'il faut
aussi protéger des PME aussi protéger
les entreprises de taille intermédiaires
industrielles exposée à la concurrence
internationale c'est pour ça qu'avec la
première ministre on fait un choix
différent mais très protecteur nous
avons obtenu des fournisseurs que la
facture moyenne ne puisse pas dépasser
les 280 euros le mégawattheure en
moyenne sur l'année 2023 je rappelle que
beaucoup de boulangers vous avez raison
de le souligner sont pris en tenaille
entre l'augmentation du prix de la
farine l'augmentation du prix des
matières premières et des coûts de
l'électricité qui pouvaient atteindre
7800000 euros le mégawattheure là ils
ont la garantie que leur facture sera
plafonnée à 280 euros en moyenne
mégawattheure c'est une protection
majeure et nécessaire pour les
boulangers si certains ont encore des
difficultés ils peuvent bénéficier du
report de charge de l'amortisseur sur
l'électricité et du guichet sur lequel
pour ouvrir réclamer des subventions
s'ils en ont encore besoin qui peuvent
amortir la facture de 40%. donc je crois
très sincèrement que nous avons pris
avec Elisabeth borne toutes les
dispositions nécessaires pour protéger
une profession à laquelle nous sommes
les boulangers et protéger en priorité
toutes les très petites entreprises de
France bien entendu ma porte et celle
d'Olivia Grégoire reste toujours ouverte
à la discussion merci la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue
Jean-François Husson pour le groupe les
républicains
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre Bruno Le Maire finalement
acteur économique acte de Monsieur le
Ministre j'entends votre brevet
d'autosatisfaction mais il y a quelques
instants encore j'avais un chef
d'entreprise au téléphone qui regroupe
les demandes de nombreux acteurs
économiques les boulangers ça a été dit
vous l'avez dit il en manque et c'est
grave mais également l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques qui aujourd'hui ne
comprennent pas l'absence de vision
stratégique du gouvernement pour venir
en aide et en soutien quand vous parlez
de
280 euros c'est grosso modo jusqu'à
350% d'augmentation par rapport à des
prix récents quand et comment les
acteurs économiques peuvent-ils tous
subir cette concurrence le risque et
vous le savez c'est d'avoir un mur de
cessation d'activité par de faillite BPI
France près 70 000 euros monsieur le
ministre considérez-vous aujourd'hui
avoir pris toutes les mesures pour
répondre aux besoins de l'ensemble des
entreprises qui font vivre la maison
France
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Économie des Finances
Bruno Le Maire
monsieur le proton général on n'est
jamais certain d'avoir pris toutes les
mesures
c'est pas la première crise que j'ai à
gérer nous avons géré avec le
gouvernement la crise du covid avec
votre soutien votre compréhension nous
avons mis en place un quoi qu'il en
coûte parce que la richesse française
était effondrée la production s'était
effondrée et il y avait un risque de
faillite par vague de successives et
d'une explosion du chômage de masse et
on m'avait averti de ce risque là il ne
s'est rien passé nous avons protégé le
monde économique protégé les
entrepreneurs protégés les entreprises
évitez un chômage de masse nous avons
géré avec efficacité la crise du covid
face à la crise de l'inflation le quoi
qu'il en coûte n'est pas la bonne
solution le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
jeter de l'essence sur l'incendie et ne
pas se débarrasser de l'inflation vous
nous reprochez de pas avoir de vision
stratégique je pense que nous avons une
vision stratégique qui est de faire
baisser l'inflation dans le courant de
l'année 2023 et ne rien faire qui puisse
prolonger l'inflation dans les années
qui viennent le quoiqu'il en coûte
aujourd'hui sans doute que ça servirait
immédiatement certaines aux entreprises
mais l'ensemble de la population
française se verrait exposer au maintien
d'un niveau très élevé d'inflation avec
tous les dommages que ça représente pour
les entreprises et tous les dommages que
ça représente pour les ménages donc nous
avons choisi une voie qui est plus
difficile mais j'ai toujours considéré
que la voix difficile et en général la
meilleure celle qui consiste à cibler
les entreprises qui en ont le plus
besoin les très petits entreprises a été
signés tout à l'heure et qui n'ont pas
les reins suffisamment solides pour
réagir elles ont des tarifs
préférentiels elles ont une protection
elles ont un guichet qui était
maintenues au 1er janvier elles ont le
report des charges elles ont dans chaque
département un numéro d'appel 1.06 d'un
conseiller qui peut les aider elles ont
la possibilité d'étaler les prêts
garantis si elles le souhaitent reste
les PME avec lesquels nous sommes en
discussion nous voulons protéger notre
outil industriel protéger nos PME
protéger nos entreprises de taille
intermédiaires qui elles sont exposées à
la concurrence internationale et ne
peuvent pas augmenter leur prix parce
que sinon elles perdront leur marché là
aussi nous bon le nécessaire notre
vision stratégique c'est protection
immédiates de ceux qui en ont besoin
faire baisser l'inflation sur le moyen
terme pour se débarrasser de cette plaie
et sur le long terme continuer une
politique de l'offre qui favorise la
compétitivité de nos entreprises je sais
vous nous rejoindre sur ce point-là
monsieur
le ministre vous avez il y a peu
expliqué que vous souhaitiez parler aux
fournisseurs d'énergie ben écoutez vous
en avez inquiet tout trouvé sous la main
et que vous contrôlez entièrement il
s'appelle EDF donc mettez-vous au
travail et rapidement pour apporter des
solutions je rappelle je rappelle que
pour EDF nous payons ici les choix
funestes menés depuis 10 ans pour
arrêter la production d'électricité
nucléaire on en paye très charmant le
prix
monsieur le ministre je l'ai dit nous
avons besoin d'avoir une vision
stratégique
en domaine énergétique pour travailler
sur les énergies renouvelables pour
travailler sur l'autonomie énergétique
et pour travailler sur notre
souveraineté énergétique notamment dans
le renouvelable et dans le nucléaire
tout ça doit en plus améliorer le sol de
notre balance commerciale et enfin
Monsieur le Ministre TPE PME ETI grandes
entreprises les entreprises de France
ont besoin d'un soutien adapté mais
encore faut-il travailler en constance
avec ses représentants d'entreprises il
compte sur vous la France a besoin d'un
État fort à ses côtés merci
la parole est notre collègue Catherine
Morin deci pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues comme mes deux prédécesseurs
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'Économie et porte sur la situation des
boulangers en France
il y a quelques semaines j'aurais tirer
votre attention sur ce fait était
annoncé l'inscription de la baguette
française au patrimoine immatériel du
l'UNESCO mettant en valeur la filière de
la boulangerie c'est traditions et ses
savoir-faire
serait-elle alors menacée en effet dans
nos départements en ce moment les mers
nous alertent sur les graves difficultés
rencontrées par les boulangers qui
doivent faire face et ça a été rappelé à
une explosion de leur facture
d'électricité alors monsieur le ministre
vous avez bien exposé les mesures
annoncées par le gouvernement le mois
dernier la possibilité de recourir à
l'amortisseur électricité le report du
paiement des impôts et des cotisations
sociales l'étalement du paiement des
factures d'énergie les fournisseurs vous
l'avez aussi rappelé ont d'ailleurs
accepté que l'ensemble des TPE et si on
signe un contrat d'électricité au cours
du second semestre 2022 ne paie plus de
papa plus de 280 euros par mégawatt
heure en moyenne sur l'année 2023
alors tout cela est très bien mais les
dispositifs sont complexes a été rappelé
et surtout ça va se mettre en oeuvre
qu'à la fin du mois or très
immédiatement les boulangers nous
alertent sur leurs problèmes ils font
immédiatement face à une hausse
considérable du coup des matières
premières c'est plus de 30 % sur leur
charge et ils peuvent pas augmenter
perpétuellement les prix sous peine de
voir leurs clientèle BC donc leur est
grave monsieur le ministre et nombre de
boulangers sont au bord de la faillite
du dépôt de de bilan donc c'est
dramatique pour eux mais ça l'est aussi
pour nos territoires mes chers collègues
la boulangerie et le commerce le plus
élémentaire en zone rurale celui qui
maintient la vie dans dans nos villages
donc que comptez-vous faire monsieur le
Miss particulièrement peut-être en lien
avec les grandes régions qui disposent
de la compétence économique et qui
œuvrent aussi à trouver des solutions je
vous remercie
pour vous répondre parole est au
ministre
de l'Économie des Finances Monsieur le
Maire
merci à Monsieur le Président Madame
c'est un triste 4e
Husson qui me demande
qui me demande de me mettre au travail
je vous rassure je suis au travail et je
n'ai pas un très grand goût pour la
feignantise
madame Morin de saillie pour être tout à
fait concret et répondre à nos amis
boulanger aujourd'hui la seule chose que
nous demandons à nos amis boulanger
c'est d'aller soit sur leur site dédié
soit sur un pot.gouv.fr de se déclarer
comme très petites entreprises parce
qu'ils se trouvent que EDF je rassure
aussi Monsieur Jean-François Husson je
reçois EDF au minimum toutes les
semaines avec Agnès panier renacher et
avec Olivia Grégoire donc nous sommes en
contact très régulier il faut qu'il se
déclare comme très petite entreprise
parce que les fournisseurs d'énergie ne
le savent pas et il faut qu'il déclare
puisque nous venons de modifier le
formulaire qu'il souhaite bénéficier du
tarif garanti à 280 euros en moyenne
donc tous les contrats qu'ils ont pu
signer à 500 600000 euros le
mégawattheure ils sont résiliés et
automatiquement ils auront droit ce
tarif à 280 euros le mégawattheure c'est
une protection massive et pour ceux pour
lesquelles ça ne suffit pas je le
rappelle guichet unique amortisseur qui
réduit de 20% l'augmentation de la
facture et décalage du paiement des
charges lorsque c'est vraiment
nécessaire donc je crois que le maximum
a été fait reste maintenant et je veux
en dire un mot les petits et moyens
d'entreprises les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire qui est son confrontées à
la même augmentation des tarifs et qui
sont exposés à la concurrence
internationale je prends juste un
exemple très concret j'étais à
Charleville-Mézières il y a quelques
jours j'ai vu une entreprise
industrielle qui fait des plaques en
aluminium pour refroidir les véhicules
électriques et bien son fournisseur et
son acheteur qui est en l'occurrence un
constructeur automobile allemand lui dit
vous ne pouvez pas augmenter les prix
sinon je me fournis ailleurs comment
est-ce que fait cette entreprise qui est
confrontée à un acheteur qui dit je ne
bouge pas mes prix et à une augmentation
des prix de l'électricité il faut qu'on
leur apporte des solutions on y
travaille aujourd'hui nous ne voulons
pas affaiblir notre base industrielle à
cause de cette crise énergétique
merci la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Marie-Claude varia pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'aurais pu
vous adresser monsieur le ministre ma
question par la poste mais il aurait
fallu que je prenne mon mal en patience
que je fasse le choix du thème revers et
son délai désormais de J + 3 ou alors
que je paie une lettre I une illette
rouge que je devrais scanner avant de
l'importer sur un site internet afin
qu'un agent des postes l'imprime et la
transporte jusque chez vous cet agent
aurait même accès à ma correspondance
aussi confidentielle soit-elle le timbre
rouge n'est plus et vous entendez faire
passer cela comme une lettre à la poste
expression vouée à la désuétude selon
vous la mesure effective depuis le 1er
janvier est un pas de plus vers la
désagrégation du service public qui doit
assurer l'égalité et l'équité et il n'y
a pas de plan B cette dématérialisation
synonyme de déshumanisation
ignore la fracture numérique qui
concerne selon l'Insee 13 millions de
Français vont-ils devenir des
sous-citoyens en conséquence vous lancez
dans 68 communes expérimentations de la
réduction de fréquences du passage du
facteur derrière la tournée du facteur
monsieur le ministre l'accueil à un
guichet ce sont des liens humains qui se
tissent bien souvent avec les plus
fragiles et les plus défavorisés or nous
savons que tout ce qui coupe les liens
sociaux abîment la démocratie si ce que
nous a dit à nouveau ce que nous dit à
nouveau cette mesure c'est que la
machine exclure tourne à plein régime
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
stopper cette opération de cases du
service public essentiel pour la
population quand le gouvernement va-t-il
entendre qu'un service public n'est pas
voué à être rentable
pour vous répondre la parole et
communiste déléguée dans le charges de
la transition et des télécommunications
monsieur barreau devait la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice varias vous interroge le
gouvernement sur l'évolution de la
politique de courrier du groupe La Poste
à laquelle nous sommes très attentifs et
vigilant avec la première ministre et
ministre de l'économie et des finances
et il ne nous a pas échappé
qu'effectivement les les nouvelles les
évoluent les évolutions nouvelles ont
suscité de la part de nos concitoyens
certaines questions et inquiétudes
légitimes permettez-moi de vous rappeler
les deux raisons pour lesquelles la
Poste fait évoluer aujourd'hui son offre
de courrier la première c'est que les
usages de nos concitoyens ont évolué là
où ils envoyaient 45 lettres
prioritaires en 2010 il n'en envoie que
5 en moyenne en 2021 ce qui ne veut
évidemment pas dire qu'il ne faut pas en
envoyer et que par ailleurs les
évolutions prévues par le groupe de la
Poste permettrait selon les calculs du
groupe d'économiser 60 000 tonnes de CO2
par an soit 25% de la consommation du
groupe et par conséquent grâce notamment
à l'arrêt du transport aérien dans
l'Hexagone ceci étant dit si vous voulez
bien me laisser terminer mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs quelques
éléments qui je l'espère seront de
nature à vous rassurer d'abord les
timbres qui ont été les timbres rouges
qui ont été achetés avant la fin de
l'année sont évidemment fonctionnels
d'autre part la présence du facteur 6
jours sur 7 n'est pas remise en question
tout
usagé pourra se faire conduire au bureau
de poste à tout moment par un facteur
c'est un engagement du groupe La Poste
et enfin le la lettre service plus qui
arrive après deux jours et la lettre
verte qui arrive après trois jours
seront évidemment disponibles enfin
c'est l'histoire de l'expérimentation
que vous avez évoqué elle ne remet en
aucun cas en question la présence tous
les jours du facteur sur les territoires
et pour toutes les activités de
distribution de la poste je vous
remercie madame barrière
monsieur Albi tiens avec mon groupe
c'est qu'après l'hôpital le rail
l'énergie la disparition du timbre rouge
monsieur le ministre symbolise le
démantèlement de nos services publics
patrimoine de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
avec l'attaque contre notre système de
retraite c'est l'ensemble du dispositif
de solidarité qui est mis en cause sous
les injections de Bruxelles
l'exaspération des Français est à son
paroxysme en ce début d'année allez-vous
enfin les entendre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Didier
Rambaud
pour le groupe du Rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous
changeons d'années mais les défis liés à
l'actualité eux persistent en ce début
d'année où les cérémonies de voeux
rythme nos soirées nos semaines nous
sommes tous ici interpellés par les élus
locaux les professionnels des TPE des
PME et nos concitoyens sur la crise
énergétique actuelle interpellé à de
nombreuses reprises sur les conséquences
mais aussi sur la réponse politique et
économique du gouvernement être
entrepreneur requiert du sang-froid et
beaucoup d'amnégation la période
actuelle en exige encore davantage en
effet cela a été dit par mes collègues
précédemment à l'image des boulangers de
notre pays parfois rares survivants du
commerce de proximité dans nos
territoires et particulièrement impacté
par l'inflation des coûts liés à
l'énergie de nombreux professionnels des
TPE et des PME n'arrivent pas toujours à
identifier le niveau d'aide dont ils
peuvent bénéficier et ils ne disposent
pas toujours du temps nécessaire pour
décrypter les différents dispositifs mis
en place par le gouvernement des
dispositifs inédits pertinents et adapté
qui gagneront à être rappelé
collectivement au plus grand nombre
alors face à la désinformation parfois
la démagogie et aux approximations pour
que tout artisan boulanger de notre pays
puissent bénéficier des aides
considérables en vigueur et continuer de
travailler avec davantage d'optimistes
je souhaite profiter de ces séances
madame la ministre pour vous interroger
sur le travail qui a été mené pour les
Françaises et les Français au-delà de
leur modalités ces dispositifs sont-ils
efficaces sont-ils suffisants les
réponses apportées aux boulangers
symboles des professionnels impactés
ont-elles été entendues et enfin
concrètement pour que chacune et chacun
puisse bénéficier des aides comment
l'étape entendu accompagné les
professionnels pour faciliter leurs
démarches merci on vous répondent la
parole est à Madame Olivia Grégoire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Député le sénateur Rambo
nous nous adaptons à la situation une
situation qui est compliquée pour nos
artisans et pour nos boulangers en
particulier
deux trois éléments 12 milliards d'euros
mobilisés au moment où on se parle 12
milliards d'euros pour aider nos PME not
TPE plus vous êtes petit plus vous êtes
exposé plus vous êtes protégé vous êtes
un boulanger 80% ils sont les chiffres
de la Confédération des boulangers
dépasse les 36 qui le volts Ampère ça a
été mentionné plafond du TRV tarif
réglementé de vente vous avez un prix
garanti de 280 euros le mégawattheure
vous n'avez qu'une chose à faire une
chose à faire remplir une case je suis
une TPE sur l'attestation qui se
trouvera à différents endroits pour être
sûr que vous la trouviez en tant que
boulanger sur votre espace professionnel
sur votre fournisseur en ligne là où
vous recevez vos factures mais aussi dès
maintenant sur le site impôts gouv.fr
sur la page d'accueil l'attestation est
disponible on peut la télécharger on
coche une cache une TPE je veux
bénéficier des conditions tarifaires et
ce sera mise en œuvre dès les prochaines
semaines sur votre facture si ça ne
suffit pas l'A fournisseur vient c'est
très pratique là c'est pareil rien à
faire vous allez cocher la case TPE rien
à faire la facture tiendra on prendra en
compte 15 à 20% de baisse directement
sur la facture si vous êtes une TPE mais
aussi une PME ça suffit pas un beau
point gouv.fr et là je me permets là
aussi de répondre à Monsieur Husson les
aides sur un beau bois
toutes les questions s'il vous plaît
mais à l'orateur qui a posé la question
[Applaudissements]
ça fait juste six mois que les aides
sont sur un pot.gouv.fr il me semble
important de rappeler que les aides je
passe mon temps à ça
expliquez juste que sur les aides
d'Octobre Novembre Décembre on peut en
disposer dès le 16 janvier en allant sur
un beau point gouv.fr une dernière chose
quand on est un artisan on a confiance
en Celui qui déclare votre TVA tous les
mois on travaille avec son
expert-comptable je travaille avec les
experts-comptables qui sont aussi aux
côtés de nos artisans en cas de doute
appelez-les nous travaillons ensemble
pour mieux accompagner au niveau des
artisans boulangers je vous remercie
la parole était notre collègue Monique
Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le ministre hier soir en
écoutant les annonces de madame la
Première ministre j'ai pensé à des amis
des connaissances Isabelle Jean-Marc
Philippe la première travaille dans
lagroalimentaire depuis 40 ans et elle
devait prendre sa retraite à 62 ans elle
devra travailler un an et trois mois de
plus le deuxième il est charpentier il
entre dans le dispositif carrière longue
mais qui sera repoussée et donc il devra
travailler plusieurs mois de plus le
troisième veine de perdre son emploi à
60 ans peu d'espoir d'en retrouver un et
une durée d'indemnisation du chômage que
vous venez généreusement de réduire et
la perspective d'un meilleur revenu
produit par la retraite qui s'éloigne
vous allez faire payer votre réforme
idéologique par ceux qui travaillent
depuis longtemps déjà qui cotise depuis
longtemps déjà et qui ont les métiers
les plus difficiles et les moins bien
rémunérés et par les précaires et dans
le même temps vous ne demandez aucune
contrepartie aux employeurs vous refusez
obstinément de mobiliser les gains
parfois faramineux engrangé par plein
depuis quelques mois alors monsieur le
ministre vous qui ne cessez de mettre en
avant la valeur travail pourquoi
maltraitez-vous à ce point les
travailleurs
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail du plein d'emploi de
l'insertion monsieur dupes merci
monsieur le Président Madame la madame
la sénatrice pardonnez-moi la réforme
est nécessaire j'ai évoqué la raison
pour laquelle il fallait la faire pour
sauver le système par répartition j'ai
aussi dit qu'il fallait faire avec le
plus de justice possible il y a deux
éléments qui répondent très précisément
à votre question le premier élément
c'est que nous avons dans le cadre de la
concertation que j'ai menée depuis
plusieurs mois travailler avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux tous
les partenaires sociaux tous les
syndicats toutes les organisations
patronales et avec les groupes
politiques nous avons consulté et nous
avons nous avons abouti nous avons
abouti sur un certain nombre de
convergences ça n'efface pas les
désaccords sur l'âge mais il y a des
convergences sur la question de la
pénibilité nous modifions contre le
compte de personnel de prévention avec
l'ensemble des six critères pour en
faciliter l'acquisition des points nous
créons la possibilité d'un véritable
congé de reconversion nous faisons en
sorte de mieux protéger ceux qui
travaillent de nuit en équipe postée
nous allons retravailler sur la question
des ports de charge des postures
pénibles
la délibérations pour faire en sorte que
les accords de prévention soit là et
c'est un milliard d'euros sur cinq ans
qui seront consacrés au financement de
la prévention tout en renforçant la
possibilité de partir de manière
anticipée dans ce cas d'un suivi médical
renforcé sur les carrières longues vous
l'avez évoqué nous maintenons évidemment
et bien évidemment le départ à 58 ans
pour tous ceux qui ont cotisé 5
trimestres avant 16 ans nous maintenons
le dispositif existant celui qui permet
de partir avec deux ans d'avance pour
ceux qui ont cotisé 5 trimestres avant
20 ans et nous créons un nouveau
dispositif qui va s'appliquer très
certainement à ceux que vous avez évoqué
pour que ceux qui ont cotisé 5
trimestres avant 18 ans et je pense tout
particulièrement apprentis que ceci
puisse partir avec quatre ans d'avance
et à 60 ans sans qu'il y ait de bouger
d'âge pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler plus tôt la vérité madame la
sénatrice elle est peut-être sur deux
points le premier c'est que les exemples
que vous avez cités les amis que vous
avez auquel vous avez pensé je souhaite
pour vous que ce soit des amis
imaginaires parce que le principal
bouger le principal décalage de la rage
de départ c'est la hausse de la durée de
cotisation vous avez voté en 2013 et la
deuxième chose que je vais vous dire
c'est quand vous écoutant et je j'ai en
tête les propos du responsable du parti
socialiste qui s'est converti à la
doctrine de Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous avez
ainsi perdu le sens de la raison et la
responsabilité
[Applaudissements]
madame
monsieur le ministre qu'il est doux à
mes oreilles de vous de me faire des
remarques à moi sur ce qu'a fait ma
famille politique et ce que nous avons
voté quand ça vient de vous monsieur le
ministre vous et moi savons très bien
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quelques souvenirs monsieur le
ministre dans le département des Landes
avec un de mes grands anciens qui
s'appelait Henri Emmanuelli et que vous
aimiez beaucoup à l'époque de vous
appréciez beaucoup à l'époque voilà donc
il fallait pas me tenter monsieur le
ministre le corps le corps dit que la
part des retraites dans le pays B c'est
14 % que ça ne bouge pas et que donc le
système n'est pas en danger les critères
de pénibilité que vous venez de donner
c'est vous qui les avez enlevés en 2018
quand vous êtes arrivés au gouvernement
et vous pouvez le traduire comme vous
voulez monsieur le ministre mais cette
réforme vous la faites uniquement payer
par les salariés et par les plus
modestes des salariés et j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure des réactions quand je
citais mes amis qui ne sont pas
imaginaires croyez-le j'ai entendu oh oh
mais quand on a travaillé 42 ans et
qu'on demande de travailler un an de
plus c'est un an de trop
la parole est maintenant madame la
Présidente Sophie prima pour le gros
plaid républicain
merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adressait à Madame pagnès
Agnès panière une hachée depuis un an
notre pays traverse une crise
énergétique effroyable le gouvernement
allume bien sûr des contrefeux nous
avons entendu quelques explications
bouclier tarifaire amortisseur filet de
sécurité 24 milliards d'euros en 2022 43
milliards en 2023 l'échec comme mode de
gouvernement sauterait dangereux vous le
savez financé par de la dette mal
calibrée complexe dans leur exécution
insuffisant toujours insuffisant à
défaut de solutions structurelles vous
arrosez le sable avec de l'eau la
solution structurelle elle est
européenne car nous sommes aujourd'hui
prisonniers de l'architecture européenne
du prix d'électricité liant électricité
gaz charbon madame la ministre l'état de
guerre a pulvérisé le marché énergétique
la disparition du gaz russe la
déséquilibrer profondément et
probablement
définitivement il faut donc tirer les
conséquences de cet état de fait et
abolir immédiatement les mécanismes de
concurrence qui génèrent l'architecture
du prix de conseils européens en Conseil
européen nous ne voyons rien venir nous
ne voyons rien bouger à défaut pour la
France d'avoir le poids désormais
suffisant en Europe pour faire bouger
les choses demander des dérogations
immédiates d'autres l'ont fait y compris
dans des pays où l'interoparabilité est
forte madame la ministre c'est urgent on
ne peut plus attendre les prochains
conseils européens notre économie ne le
supportera pas merci de nous dire votre
action
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre
de la transition énergétique madame la
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la Présidente prima vous l'avez
dit nous avons d'abord agi au service
des ménages au service des entreprises
et au service des collectivités locales
en prenant le plus rapidement possible
des mesures qui font qu'aujourd'hui la
France
offre ou permet à ces différentes
catégories d'avoir le prix de
l'électricité le plus bas d'Europe je
veux le rappeler car ce n'est pas une
politique du chèque c'est une politique
qui est assis aussi sur une contribution
sur la rente infrarmorginale
c'est-à-dire le surplus de bénéfice que
crée cette situation particulière de
crise énergétique que vous avez souligné
sur plus de bénéfices chez nos
producteurs d'électricité donc c'est
aussi une approche où nous savons gérer
le budget de l'État à de bonnes fins
avec des aides proportionnées les
ménages et les TPE étant les mieux
protégés j'ai obtenu cela a été rappelé
avec Bruno Le Maire et déjà Grégoire ce
plafonnement du prix de l'électricité
des contrats à 280 euros du
mégawattheure vous soulignez très
justement que l'action doit se passer
aussi au niveau européen vous avez
raison de le souligner parce que ce que
nous subissons c'est d'abord un acte de
guerre 40% de l'approvisionnement en
Europe de gaz et d'origine russe 22% de
la production d'électricité européenne
est basée sur le gaz ça c'est une
réalité physique dont il faut prendre
compte vous savez également on en a
parlé encore ce matin en commission
développement durable et à faire
économique pour la présentation du
projet de loi nucléaire que la situation
de notre part que nucléaire nous rend
aujourd'hui dépendant de
l'approvisionnement en électricité de la
part d'autres pays européens et donc
c'est une réalité également physique
dont il faut prendre compte alors nous
avons agi en européen tout ce qui nous
permet aujourd'hui de passer cette crise
cet hiver avec une baisse des prix
d'électricité certes pas satisfaisante
mais nettement inférieur au début de
l'année grâce au stockage de gaz grâce
au flap plafonnement du prix du gaz et
du aux décisions que nous avons pris au
niveau européen et la Commission
présentera au premier trimestre grâce à
l'action du gouvernement une proposition
sur le marché l'évolution du marché
d'électricité dans le sens que vous
appelez de vos vœux je vous remercie
madame la Présidente
j'ai encore quelques instants je rêve
d'un pays fort en Europe madame les
ministres nous étions un pays fort en
Europe capable d'imposer des décisions à
l'Europe or là il y a urgence il y a une
grande urgence car à la fin du premier
trimestre quand l'Europe aura pris ses
décisions peut-être nous aurons dépensé
dans le budget de l'état des milliards
d'euros au travers de chèques et nous
n'aurons toujours pas de solution
structurelle donc je rêve d'un pays fort
capable de faire bouger l'Europe et de
prendre des décisions au bénéfice de
notre pays merci
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue
victorinurel pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains vous avez la
parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur la
collègue
contenu de la gravité du sujet et de son
caractère interministériel ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
j'ai associé mes collègues Catherine
qu'on connaît victoire jasmin elle porte
sur le non-lieu prononcée le 2 janvier
dernier dans l'enquête sous la
contamination et la pollution au
chlordécone je respecte les décisions de
justice mais à l'espèce personne ne
pourrait s'en satisfaire cette décision
est un indéniable déni un déni pouvant
allumer des brasiers puisqu'il y aurait
Nick coupable ni responsable bien
qu'attendu cette décision ajoute au
scandale d'État un scandale judiciaire
madame la Première ministre au-delà des
actions menées par tous les
gouvernements et par le vôtre des plans
mis en place et de la reconnaissance de
la carence fautive des pouvoirs publics
je considère pour autant que l'État
reste co-responsable majeur de cette
tragédie et en reste donc notre corps
comptable 46 ans après les premières
alertes 16 ans après la première plainte
vous ne pouvez rester indifférente alors
je formule ici quatre demandes au-delà
des suites que les partis civils ne
manquons pas garantie contentez-vous
tout faire dans le respect du droit pour
que le parquet rouvre ce dossier
êtes-vous prêt à créer un fonds
d'indemnisation pour toutes les victimes
etes-vous prêtes à faire pour les
victimes du chlordicônes ce qui a été
fait pour les victimes de l'amiante
êtes-vous prêtes à renforcer l'action de
l'État dans la recherche fondamentale
dans la dépollution des eaux et des sols
j'attends de vous une réponse humaine
débarrassée de toutes veines polémiques
pour vous répondre la parole
Jean-François
caracoche des Outre-mer monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire hier à l'Assemblée
nationale je constate comme vous la
décision prise librement par les
autorités judiciaires un membre du
gouvernement ne peut qu'en prendre acte
mais j'ai bien lu les attendus de
l'ordonnance il pointe une
responsabilité collective dans ce
scandale sanitaire
mais vous l'avez dit cela la Moinerie en
rien la responsabilité de l'État face à
ce scandale reconnu d'ailleurs pour la
première fois par le Président de la
République en 2018 et nous devons
continuer d'avancer sur ce chemin
notre priorité à tous et de protéger la
santé de nos concitoyens
des délaisseurs économiques impactés de
renforcer la recherche
avec Gérald Darmanin avec le ministre de
la Santé le gouvernement s'est engagé et
s'engage encore à répondre à ces enjeux
plusieurs avancées fortes j'insiste là
dessus ont déjà été obtenus la
reconnaissance du cancer de la prostate
comme maladie professionnelle ouvrant
droit indemnisation
analyse gratuite du taux de chordicône
dans le sang analyse des sols ou encore
conséquent travaux de recherche engagés
pour la dépollution des sols
le colloque scientifique et les
rencontres du terrain de terrain du mois
de décembre ont été l'occasion de porter
à la connaissance ces nombreuses
avancées mais ils ont montré aussi qu'il
y avait encore beaucoup à faire dans ce
cadre je note vous propositions qu'il
nous faut étudier avec attention et
volonté d'aboutir si l'ordonnance est le
droit et la chose jugée cela nous
empêchera pas de continuer à avancer je
me rends en Martinique dès demain en
partie pour cela la cordonnatrice du
plan chlordécone m'accompagnera à cet
effet je vous remercie
que vous n'ayez pas saisi d'occasion ici
pour marquer votre considération aux
populations de Martinique et de
Guadeloupe frappait de sidération et
déjà marqué dans leur chair je le
ministre vous me faites une réponse que
je connais et qui est celle d'un
communicant vous savez fort bien que
tous les gouvernements ont engagé les
actions et qu'aujourd'hui
la les plans cordées qu'on est notamment
le 4 est insuffisant il est sous doté et
il est sous-financé 2,4 millions pour la
recherche fondamentale par an ce n'est
pas suffisant il faudrait au moins 5
10,8 millions par an alors que nous
mettions 12 millions en 2010 avec
Monsieur Sarkozy et 13 millions en 2016
il faut compter suffisant monsieur le
Président je demande que le gouvernement
nous fasse bénéficier du préjudice
d'anxiété à l'instar de l'amiante merci
la parole est à notre collègue
Alain bidon pour le groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de la Santé le
président de la République a dit
clairement on a insisté de reconstruire
notre système de santé pour l'adapter et
satisfaire les attentes des
professionnels comme des patients mais
pour y parvenir une réforme globale de
l'organisation de ses soins de leur mode
de financement et des synergies à mettre
en œuvre est nécessaire pour restituer
une attractivité perdue et profondé un
système innovant performant viable et
humains hélas les orientations proposées
posent davantage de questions que de
solutions efficaces et urgentes le
financement est absent totalement de ce
discours présidentiel sortir de la T2A
par exemple dès le prochain bel effet 16
pour lui substituer une rémunération
basée sur des objectifs de santé
publique négociées à l'échelle du
territoire fondé sur un critère
populationnel non défini ça laisse
perplexe comment imaginer que l'objectif
déficience puisse être tout en rendant
la porte de financement à l'activité
minoritaire c'est bel et bien à notre
avis sonner le glas de l'hôpital quand
on s'y mille postes d'assistants
médicaux supplémentaires c'est pendant
trois ans l'assurance maladie qui
peraque quid de la pré et comment
l'assurance maladie paiera-t-elle quand
on sait que les 4000 assistants déjà
mises en place coûtent à celle-ci 160
millions d'euros les propositions
concernant la médecine de ville ne sont
pas à hauteur et ne permettent pas
d'enrayer la crise de vocation ni la
propagation des déserts médicaux
monsieur le ministre comment
entendez-vous répondre avec précision et
concrètement aux attentes des soignants
hospitaliers et libéraux sans procéder à
une refondation complète des modes de
financement entre les différents
sénateurs que les différents financeurs
pardon que sont la sécurité sociale de
pas d'une part et les mutuelles d'autre
part
pour vous répondre la parole commise de
la santé de la prévention chez Brown
c'est le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Milon
le 6 janvier dernier le président de la
République a tenu un discours devant les
soignantes traçant un nouveau cap une
feuille de route pour la refondation
complète de notre système de santé avec
un diagnostic lucide mais surtout un
changement dans l'analyse et la méthode
vous le savez passer d'un système qui a
été construit autour de l'offre de soins
forcément concurrentiel vers un système
pour plus répondre aux besoins de santé
de nos concitoyens beaucoup a déjà été
faits que ce soit dans le Ségur que ce
soit entre autres la suppression du
numérus clausus mais nous devons aller
effectivement plus loin plus vite pour
répondre aux défis qui sont devant nous
et qui d'ailleurs concernent l'ensemble
des pays européens et d'une façon
générale l'ensemble des pays
industrialisés il y a des axes forts
régler le problème à l'échelle de chaque
territoire sortir de cette logique
concurrentielle pour travailler en
complémentarité ville hôpital clinique
médecin paramédicaux médicaux
administratif et puis retrouver des
collectifs à l'échelle humaine comme en
particulier l'échelle des services pour
l'hôpital redonner du temps médical de
redonner du temps de soin est un enjeu
majeur car comme la préciser le
président ce n'est pas tout de suite que
nous aurons les médecins que nous
attendons après la suppression du
numérique clausus alors comment faire
laisser les soignants faire ce pourquoi
ils sont formés c'est-à-dire le soin
développer les assistants médicaux en
l'aidant à cette installation les
maisons de santé plus professionnelle à
l'hôpital en intégrant les logiciels les
administratifs au plus près du service
il faut utiliser les mieux les
compétences de chacun la plus-value de
chaque professionnel au sein d'équipe
traitante autour du médecin traitant ou
au sein des services de l'hôpital
résonner territoire par territoire
réformer vous l'avez dit le financement
de notre système de santé en particulier
en sortant de la T2A qui n'est qu'un
financement calacte en s'ouvrant vers un
financement certes toujours à l'acte
pour certains mais qui répond aux
besoins de santé de la population et qui
est un financement à la qualité à
l'efficience nous l'avons fait déjà pour
les services d'urgence nous allons
continuer à le faire pour l'ensemble les
médecins généralistes sont déjà dans cet
axe ce sont des engagements forts envers
les soignants envers nos concitoyens
pour leur santé et soyez assurés que
nous allons les développer très
rapidement puisque les échéances sont
courtes et que je serai totalement
motivé et mobilisés pour se faire cela
Monsieur
oui merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
monsieur le Président les propositions
que vous venez de nous faire sont des
propositions que nous faisons depuis des
années on a déjà entendu sous différents
ministres depuis madame Marisol Touraine
en passant par un amusant et par
Monsieur Véran il y a finalement rien de
nouveau à ce niveau-là il y a donc
aucune vision alternative qui structure
la réflexion du gouvernement moi je vous
en donner quelques unes qui vous
permettez dans le système de santé qui
se construisent il y a les soins
primaires il y a le panais de son
régulier il y a la mise en réseau
obligatoire il y a un pilotage fort et
décentralisé on n'a jamais parlé de
décentralisation dans le pilotage des
ARS et c'est bien dommage une réflexion
globale sur le financement et non pas
simplement une réflexion telle que vous
la donnée mais une réflexion sur
l'ensemble du financement en particulier
sur les dépenses merci
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
Antoine Lévy pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues la question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué chargé du
numérique monsieur le ministre comme ma
collègue Parisse tout à l'heure et
beaucoup de Français et beaucoup de
Français je me pose cette question où va
le service public postale aujourd'hui en
effet depuis le 1er janvier les timbres
rouges réservés aux envois de l'aide
priorités ne sont plus commercialisées
la modernité selon la poste c'est soit
disant la vie d'être rouge il faudra
donc se connecter en ligne pour rédiger
ou scanner une lettre qui sera ensuite
retranscrite puis imprimée par une
agenda poste avant d'être envoyé
pourquoi faire simple quand on peut
faire compliqué oui la confidentialité
dans des écrits dans ce nouveau process
cette prétendue révolution pose surtout
le problème de l'accès de tous au
service public postal l'égalité est
portant l'un des grands principes de la
notion de service public dans notre pays
la réalité c'est qu'en pratique
l'électronisme touche près de 14
millions de concitoyens surtout en
milieu rural
alors certes ils pourront toujours aller
dans un bureau de poste pour envoyer
leur lettre prioritaire si bien sûr il y
en a un ici n'est pas fermé mais comment
expliquer aux citoyen qui choisit les
présidents utilisaient un automate une
borne pour faire envoyer leur lettre
après avoir scanné des documents de plus
en pratique les agents de 6 bureaux de
poste ne pourront pas toujours aider ces
personnes lorsque l'influence est très
importante elles seront laissées seules
devant l'automate cette réforme donne
comme une impression de rajouter de la
complexité à quelque chose qui était à
la base fort simple en fait nous
apprenons également qu'à partir du mois
de mars le courrier ne serait plus
distribué tous les jours mais un jour
sur deux puis pourquoi pas un jour sur
trois cette réforme est à
expérimentation d'un certain département
mais elle risque d'être généralisée à
toute la France
mais le risque est grand que cette
réforme désorganise le service postal et
qu'elle aboutissent infinie à la
suppression de nombreux emplois alors ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
et vous n'avez pas répondu tout à
l'heure allez vous laisser continuer à
se déliter ce service public historique
il est urgent d'agir avant que nous
devenions tous un vrai je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste déléguée en charge du
télécommunications sur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Levi je ne
reviendrai pas sur les constats qui ont
conduit le groupe La Poste à prendre ses
décisions mais je veux réaffirmer une
nouvelle fois le profond attachement du
gouvernement à l'université à
l'universalité du service postal qui est
d'ailleurs inscrite dans la loi je veux
redire une nouvelle fois que la présence
du facteur est maintenue 6 jours sur 7
que tout
usagé rencontrant des difficultés ayant
la nécessité d'effectuer un envoi
prioritaire pourra se faire accompagner
par un facteur au bureau de poste et
qu'en fin les services liés à la lettre
service plus qui arrive deux jours après
à destination et la lettre verte qui
arrive trois jours après à destination
seront évidemment assurés s'agissant de
l'expérimentation que vous citez elle
vise à tester de nouvelles modalités de
distribution dans les 68 communes que
vous évoquiez mais en aucun cas elle ne
remet en question la présence tous les
jours du facteur sur l'ensemble du
territoire en revanche monsieur le
sénateur je ne pourrais laisser dire sur
d'autres bancs peut-être que ce
gouvernement ne se désintéresse de la
fracture territoriale avec 2600 maisons
françaises réparties sur l'ensemble du
territoire avec action cœur de ville
avec petite ville de demain avec
territoire d'industrie avec 4000
conseillers numériques qui ont
accompagné un million 300000 personnes
depuis un an sur le territoire national
c'est ce gouvernement qui a mis fin à
une quinzaine d'années d'aveuglement sur
l'aggravation de la fracture
territoriale et je crois que vous en
conviendrez soyez monsieur le sénateur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
convaincus de l'attachement de ce
gouvernement à la résorption de la lutte
contre la fracture territoriale
quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre désolé mais je ne
suis pas absolument pas convaincu je
peux vous confirmer et ici tous mes
collègues sénateurs le confirmeront la
Poste ne distribue pas six jours sur 7
mais certaines fois 4 jours ou 5 jours
et que cette expérimentation inquiète
énormément de français dans tous les
territoires donc je vous le redis
qu'allez-vous faire pour éviter le
délitement du service public
la parole est à notre collègue sorry
pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères à la fin du mois de décembre
les autorités en place à Ouagadougou on
te demande des soudures prétextes le
débat de léonbassadeur de France ce
nouvel épisode des tensions qui émanent
une relation avec le Burkina Faso n'est
pas sans rappeler le scénario qui s'est
déjà produit au Mali et en Centre
Afrique illustre surtout le fait que
dans cette partie de l'Afrique où elle
apporte en vrai la France est récemment
devenue indésirable malgré l'engagement
de nos militaires contre le terrorisme
islamiste et le sacrifice de 53 d'entre
eux malgré le niveau considérable de
l'aide au développement déployé dans
cette zone prioritaire jamais la France
n'y a été tant critiquée et temps rejeté
donc il s'est concitoyens expatriés ont
subissent malheureusement les effets
mais plus largement c'est bien dans
l'ensemble du continent africain que
l'influence économique politique
diplomatique ou même culturelle de notre
pays ne cessent de s'éroder ces parts de
marché ont ainsi fondu la moitié par
rapport au début des années 2000 et ce
recul ne fait que s'accélérer depuis
l'année dernière
la France n'est plus le premier
partenaire commercial d'aucun des pays
du Maghreb dans de nombreux pays la
langue française voit son influence
reculée et maintenant concurrencé par
l'Anglais jusque dans les programmes
scolaires voir comment Rwanda en tant
que langue officielle et si la France
reste le premier pays de destination des
étudiants africains sa capacité à
attirer pour les former sur son sol les
futurs élites et désormais en recul par
rapport à d'autres destinations avec ces
formidables atouts aussi bien humain que
naturel l'Afrique est un emploi douter
un continent d'avenir mais cet avenir si
nous ne sommes pas capables de remettre
à plat l'ensemble des politiques que
nous y menons ces dernières années
risquent fort de s'écrire sans la France
depuis 2017 la situation s'est dégradée
et nous envoyons aujourd'hui les
conséquences alors madame la ministre
quelle stratégie le gouvernement tant il
mettre en œuvre au cours de ce
quinquennat pour enfin enrayer le déclin
général de française en Afrique
pour vous répondre la parole de la
ministre de l'Europe des Affaires
étrangères madame Colonna
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sén
ateurs monsieur le sénateur sorry disons
les choses en Afrique comme ailleurs les
manipulations de l'information ne
cessent de prendre de l'ampleur et dans
plusieurs pays la France est visée par
des campagnes des campagnes qui n'ont
rien de spontané on le sait et nous le
savons bien puisque la secrétaire d'État
aux partenariat internationaux étaient
hier encore au Burkina Faso je la
remercie de cette visite elle est allée
portée un message qui était clair comme
vous l'avez vu face à cela nous devons
agir mais nous devons agir avec les
moyens les outils d'une démocratie et
c'est ce que nous faisons nous opérons
un triple changement j'ai demandé à mon
ministère de le mettre en oeuvre car oui
nous devons changer l'Afrique change et
nous devons également changer un
changement de contenu il s'agit de mieux
expliquer la réalité de nos partenariats
ou l'innovation les entreprises les
artistes les jeunes ont une place
centrale changer c'est aussi se placer
au soutien de ceux qui journalisent
contre
des informations changements de support
ensuite il s'agit pour nous d'être
partout présent beaucoup plus
qu'auparavant partout présent ou se
forment les opinions africaines y
compris sur les réseaux sociaux et
permettre ainsi de nous adresser un
public plus jeune et enfin changement
d'échelle par l'accroissement du volume
de ce que nous produisons et par la
mobilisation du réseau diplomatique est
en prise avec les réalités et les
interlocuteurs locaux tout ceci monsieur
le sénateur en complément de nos
relations humaines de nos relations
économiques qui persistent qui changent
elles aussi l'enjeu est considérable
vous l'avez dit soyez assurés que notre
mobilisation les tout autant si je suis
arrivé avec quelques instants de retard
après le début de cette séance je vous
en
présente mes excuses c'est que le
Président de la République recevait le
président des Comores et après cette
session je me rendrai à 10 à Beba avec
ma collègue allemande siège de l'Union
africain donc nous sommes actifs vous le
voyez je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant de notre
collègue et il y a une poule pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de la santé doit
prévention la pénurie du médicament
sujet quasiment inexistant dans les
années 2010 devient un problème majeur
de sécurité et de souveraineté nationale
avec une aggravation des tensions depuis
la crise covid en 2023 l'outil vendons
encore et toujours de l'un de la Chine
en particulier à qui nous achetons plus
de 80% des matières premières moins de
40% des médicaments sont fabriqués en
Europe pourtant dans le monde d'après
tout serait différent le président
Macron nous l'avait assuré la France
allait retrouver sa souvenait ça
souveraineté industrielle or les
pénuries et les tensions n'ont jamais
été aussi fortes en particulier sur les
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur et à l'hôpital certains
anticancéreux ou immunosuppresseurs
utilisent dans les grèves du rhum par
exemple manque obligeant à choisir les
patients pouvant en bénéficier c'est une
perte de chance inadmissible pour les
patients et d'autres pénuries de
médicaments aussi courant que
oblige les pharmaciens à délivrer les
boîtes aux comptes de gouttes alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple quel est votre stratégie pour
retrouver une production en France ou
pour le moins en Europe
on vous répond de la parole de Toby de
la santé de la prévention chevron
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice pour Mirol
je partage en partie votre diagnostic
mais je vais préciser un petit peu les
choses deux années de crise sanitaire
celle que nous avons traversé en
bouleversé complètement notre
consommation et entraîner à la clé des
difficultés d'anticipation des volumes
de production par les industriels
parallèlement à cela nous constatons une
forte reprise de la consommation plus
13% par exemple en France pour le
paracétamol et également dans des pays
comme la Chine on le voit bien c'est une
situation qui ne concerne pas que la
France même pas que l'Europe qui est une
situation aujourd'hui mondiale
notre système d'alerte nous permet
d'anticiper
autant que faire ce peu cette situation
grâce à un suivi de nos stocks
stratégiques mais je comprends bien sûr
et je vois l'inquiétude des gens qui
vont chercher les médicaments dans les
pharmacies tout en sachant la
mobilisation remarquable des pharmaciens
qui se mobilisent très fort pour trouver
les différents produits alors face à ce
diagnostic nous avons mis en place un
traitement nous avons Agito nous
interdisons les exportations à
l'étranger ce qui est en France reste en
France nous contingentons les stocks
nous adaptons pour avoir une répartition
homogène sur l'ensemble du territoire
nous échangeons avec les laboratoires
concernés pour prioriser certaines
formes de médicaments nous avons
autorisé la reproduction d'amoxicilline
par des laboratoires en France
nous adaptons la dispensation officine
vous l'avez dit au juste besoin des
patients et nous travaillons avec les
professionnels sur les alternatives
thérapeutiques ça c'est des actions
immédiates nous allons plus loin en
reconstruisant notre souverain
industrielle mais ça va pas se refaire
en 5 minutes bien évidemment la France
investit massivement depuis plus d'un an
dans le cadre de France relance dans le
cadre de France 2030 des projets de
relocalisation très concrets sont en
train de voir le jour je pense au
paracétamol dans le projet C15 également
des masques des gants nitriles et puis à
Arras une usine pour la production de
médicaments dérivés du sang à partir de
plasma sanguin donc oui nous sommes dans
l'axe pour regagner notre souveraineté
en France au sein de l'Europe sur les
médicaments et en attendant nous faisons
le maximum pour que tous les Français
puissent avoir les traitements qui leur
sont nécessaires je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre je crois qu'il ne
faut pas se cacher derrière la crise et
les mesures que vous indiquez ils sont
en fait que des gestion de la pénurie
notre groupe propose pourtant depuis
plusieurs années dans les discussions du
PLFSS plusieurs solutions et en
particulier le renforcement de nos
capacités de production publique avec
les pharmacies centrales des hôpitaux ou
des armées ou la possible réquisition
d'entreprise et il faut surtout un plan
concerté de réindustrialisation en
France et en Europe les industriels
arguent d'un prix trop bas des
médicaments alors mettons en carte sur
table sur la fixation des prix qui est
aujourd'hui protégée par le secret des
affaires pour qu'il tienne compte des
aides publiques directes ou indirectes
dont il bénéficie la loi du marché et le
libéralisme peuvent gouverner notre
politique en matière de produits de
santé rembourser une fille par la
Sécurité Sociale donc l'argent de tous
les contribuables pour construire une
véritable indépendance de la production
il faut une politique publique forte et
volontariste
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Christine Lavarde pour le gros plaid
républicains
[Applaudissements]
président monsieur le ministre la
l'édition 2023 du CES de Las Vegas se
vient de se clôturer elle a laissé une
part large aux automobiles et à cette
obligation le PDG de stelantis Carlos
Tavares a lancé une nouvelle charge
charge contre le niveau du prix
extrêmement bas des véhicules chinois
zéro émission qui met en péril
l'industrie européenne et cette
industrie pour le seul territoire
national c'est 210000 emplois directs
auxquels il convient d'ajouter tous les
emplois indirects si j'en crois les
objectifs affichés par trois
constructeurs chinois pour les citer
Gélis sec et grutall à E3 ils envisagent
d'importer un million de véhicules sur
les territoires européens d'ici 3 ans
ils sont déjà en train de construire le
système de distribution qui leur
permettra d'atteindre cet objectif alors
certes sur le territoire national les
véhicules électriques progressent plus
que 46% d'immatriculation en 2021 mais
80% de ces véhicules sont importés et la
presse ne s'y trompe pas elle écrit
d'ailleurs le loup chinois et dans la
bergerie en effet la Chine c'est 50% de
la valeur totale d'un véhicule
électrique c'est 75% de la chaîne de
valeur des batteries c'est 90% des
moteurs électriques produits dans le
monde et face à tout ça l'industrie
européenne est en très grande difficulté
elle ne parvient même plus à pénétrer le
marché chinois alors dans cette bataille
qui vient de commencer monsieur le
ministre quels sont nos armes avez-vous
choisi une guerre de position et donc de
continuer à subir les assos chinois ou
entendez-vous sortir de notre tranchée
et lancer une guerre de mouvement
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'économie et les finances
et de la souveraineté industrielle
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire merci monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice d'abord
merci pour votre excellente question de
réponse va être très clair nous sommes
favorables à une guerre de mouvement
avec de l'offensive et de la défensive
l'offensive s'être capable d'avoir au
21ème siècle une industrie automobile
électrique en France en Europe aussi
performante que celle que nous avons eu
sur le véhicule thermique au 20e siècle
je rappelle que c'est ce gouvernement
cette majorité qui a pris l'initiative
il y a maintenant auprès de quatre ans
de mettre sur pied une filière de
batterie électrique pour être moins
dépendant de la Chine nous allons ouvrir
les deux premières usines de batterie
électrique nous avons un objectif à 2030
de produire environ 100 à 120 GW de
puissance électrique avec des batteries
produite en France sur les territoires
français vous savez vous avez travaillé
dessus que nous voulons rouvrir une
usine de lithium que nous voulons divers
nous approvisionnements nous voulons
également être indépendant en matière de
semi-conducteur qui sont absolument
indispensables sur le véhicule
électrique nous avons obtenu
l'investissement de Global fun Reese sur
le site d'esthemicro pour développer
massivement la production de ce
microducteur qui serviront aussi au
véhicules électriques donc l'objectif
est très clair être indépendant en
matière de production de véhicules
électriques ça c'est l'offensif les
matériaux les batteries les
semi-conducteurs et au bout du compte
comme l'a annoncé d'ailleurs stellantis
la production de ces véhicules
électriques sur le sol français et
croyez moi l'offensive sera très
volontariste après il y a une question
que vous soulevez qui est majeure et moi
je vous invite à participer aux travaux
que nous avons lancé sur le projet de
loi de l'industrialisation verte
jusqu'où allons-nous dans le volet
défensif
est-ce que par exemple nous réservons
les aides 7000 euros aujourd'hui par
véculé électrique à des véhicules
produits et assemblés uniquement en
France et en Europe la question est
légitime après tout d'autres le font
faut-il renforcer le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières pour
dire ça ne concerne pas uniquement le
ciment l'acier la lumière mais ça peut
aussi concerner des vrais bien
manufacturés par exemple des automobiles
je n'ai pas la réponse à ces questions
mais le défensif est capable d'avoir
l'audace de poser ces questions de
discuter avec tous les sénateurs les
sénatrices que je souhaiterais dans le
cadre du projet de loi industrialisation
verte nous sommes avec la première
ministre à mettre sur pied des volets
défensifs pour être autonome sur le
véhicule électrique
alors Monsieur le Ministre certaines des
questions que vous venez de poser
pourtant vous avez donné la réponse en
octobre dernier devant la plateforme
automobile vous avez dit qu'il fallait
pas le se laisser envahir et qu'il
fallait réserver les aides à des
véhicules produits en Europe c'est ce
que vous a proposé le Sénat nous avons
ici adopté un amendement qui venait de
diminuer de 500 millions ses aides qui
sont versées essentiellement aux
industriels chinois vous l'avez retirez
c'était pourtant une mesure de
souveraineté et qui venait aussi à
améliorer notre déficit budgétaire et
vous ne l'avez pas gardé c'est bien
dommage merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Pierre Vogel pour le groupe les
républicains
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à Madame
la Ministre Olivia Grégoire la filière
équine représente plus de 11 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires 20 000
entreprises et 66000 emplois directs
cette filière
Eric notre territoire elle est présente
dans 91% des cantons avec plus d'un
million de chevaux l'équitation c'est
aussi 2 millions de pratiquants dont 700
000 licenciés et donc la troisième
fédération olympique et le premier sport
féminin le monde du cheval s'est enfin
plus de 827 millions de recettes
directes pour l'État à travers les paris
hippiques et 295 millions d'euros à
travers la TVA
dans la période que nous traversons
beaucoup de Français ont du mal à
boucler leurs fins de mois les activités
qui ne constituent pas un luxe mais une
force économique pour nos territoires
ruraux et la passion d'un grand nombre
de nos compatriotes comme vous le savez
à la suite d'une décision de justice
européenne la filière se bat depuis plus
de 10 ans pour retrouver un taux de TVA
conforme à son caractère agricole et lui
permettant d'être compétitive je
rappellerai juste qu'en Irlande
concurrent direct de nos éleveurs la TVA
est à 4,1%. alors que le Sénat avait
voté dans le PLF un amendement
permettant de revenir à un taux réduit
pour la filière et au lendemain de
l'adoption du budget 2023 par le 49-3 la
déception est grande le président de la
République avait pourtant obtenu en 2022
la révision de la directive TVA pour
permettre à la France de revenir au taux
réduit antérieur et c'était engagé à les
appliquer dès que possible ma question
est donc simple madame la quand et par
quel véhicule législatif le gouvernement
donnera la filière équine un cadre
fiscal garantissant sa pérennité et son
développement et le respect de la parole
donnée quand vous répondre la parole est
à Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre
délégué en charge des petits des moyens
d'entreprise du commerce et de
l'artisanat je le sénateur voguel merci
pour votre question qui me permet de
souligner et remercier d'ailleurs la
constance de la position du gouvernement
sur la question du cadre fiscal de la
filière équine ça vous a été rappelé je
crois lors des débats sur le projet loi
de finance pour 2023 la cohérence du
système fiscale repose sur une
application du taux réduit de la TVA de
5,5 qui est comme vous le savez bien
réservé aux biens et services de
première nécessité évidemment des
denrées alimentaires mais aussi des
appareils les équipements pour les
personnes handicapées ou encore le
logement et la nourriture dans les
maisons de retraite dans ces deux
petites généraliser le bénéfice de taux
réduit TVA 5 5 à toutes les ventes des
idées ainsi qu'aux prestations liées à
ces animaux
se répète justifier ça poserait aussi
des difficultés en termes d'équité à
l'égard d'autres disciplines éducatives
sportives aussi dignes d'intérêt
gouvernement est attentif à la filière
équestre il apporte son soutien
significatif assez différentes
composantes je rappelle que l'ifco que
vous connaissez bien institut français
du cheval et de l'équitation dispose par
exemple aujourd'hui d'un budget de
quasiment 43 millions d'euros au
bénéfice de la filière équine ce qui
témoigne de l'engagement constant et de
la parole de l'État dans ce domaine les
échanges entre le gouvernement et la
filière sont approfondis sont réguliers
et nous souhaitons vraiment qu'il le
demeure pour continuer à continuer la
filière dans le changement de doctrine
européenne que vous avez souligné
monsieur le sénateur et surtout dans la
valorisation des savoir-faire des
pratiques des activités sportives et
culturelles essentielles sans oublier le
tourisme équestre le tourisme et
qu'est-ce qui représente en France un
million de pratiquants et qui permet une
découverte inédite de notre patrimoine
de nos régions je vous remercie et à
merci on se tient à votre disposition si
vous souhaitez que nous poursuivions les
échanges
monsieur Vogel
les dispositions actuelles sont
insuffisantes car le contexte économique
défavorable mais surtout la distorsion
de concurrence entre pays en matière de
fiscalité de TVA pour la filière équine
provoque l'annulation de certaines
courses en France faute d'un nombre
suffisant de partants et entraîne des
pertes de recettes pour le PMU et donc
pour la filière et pour le budget de
l'État l'application de taux réduite TVA
conforme au caractère agricole de la
filière et donc urgent si nous aurons
notre prochaine séance de questions
d'actualité le mercredi 18 janvier à 15h
mais mes chers collègues avant cette
séance ça c'est pour les sénateurs nous
réaliserons notre photographie officier
qui n'avait plus être prise en 2020 en
raison de la crise sanitaire
et je vous remercie de noter dans vos
agendas d'être présent à 14h20 précises
dans l'hémicycle mercredi prochain je me
permets d'assister sur l'horaire parce
qu'a début à côté du début de prise de
vue qui doit être pas dorée il sera plus
possible d'entrer dans l'hémicycle et
pratiquer l'injection de photos à
posteriori n'est pas
la bonne formule je compte donc sur vous
et nous allons nous retrouver tout à
l'heure pour le débat
à partir de 16h35 pour le débat
d'actualité sur la crise du système de
santé merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres la
séance est suspendue